[Music]
raleigh north carolina is where we go
next nate joins us there nate how can we
help
hi ken hi anthony uh love you guys
thanks for taking my call thank you sir
hey i'll try to be brief and respect
your time
i'm a 35 year old military service
member i'm married we have six kids
uh we have 253 000 in debt not counting
a house
we make close to 150 000 a year
and we just finished baby step one
after i took on a second job trying to
uh
get the plane up into the air like dave
would say
and uh you know get a head start on baby
step one now we're in baby step two
uh we've started uh doing a monthly
budget
and allocation spending plan according
to the total money makeover forms
my wife is the free-spirited one and
uh i've took the financial peace
university a couple of years ago too
and i've tried to show her the way uh
it's taken
up until now until she finally sat down
with me
over the past months uh weekends in a
row going over the allocation spending
plan the point is
every time we're going over the
allocation spending plan and budget
she she's the she's of the one of the
mind with uh
well we still got to do vacations
vacation she she just loves the
vacations wants to take the family on
vacations
and i understand that and i'm the one
who
is like well we can take vacations but
we got to stick to a really tight budget
and we're living beyond our means
no you got 253 000 in debt you can't
take not even no cheap vacation
yeah i know i uh yeah staycation is the
article from days yeah
go ahead no let's let's talk about the
253 000 real quick break it down for ao
what that's made of
what it's made of yeah the 253
total of 14 items uh one is definitely a
time share i've been listening you guys
talk about in days
one is uh three of them are student
loans
two cars what kind of cars several
credit cards
i got a 2021 nissan titan pro 4x
my wife has a 2020 nissan murano
okay what are the cars worth start with
yours
mine is worth uh worth blue
kelly blue yes around fifty thousand
fifty how much you owe right fifty five
zero how much do you owe on it uh
ten thousand more goodness gracious what
about your wife's
i'm guessing it's the same situation
what how much is hers worth
uh the murano hers is worth um
thousand how much yo on it
uh uh i think also five or ten grand
more
wait wait are these 20 20s in 2021 yeah
yeah i'm not sure that that kelly blue
blick value is accurate are you sure
that's accurate
i'm cuz how did you pay off 40 grand
almost 60 70 grand in cars
in less than a year we traded in
cars before so it was rolled over these
are rollover cars rollover cars
okay all right so pretty much what we
have right here is
is um um if the kelly blue book is right
i'm i'm seeing about 60 60 grand in
equity
and you're uh 253 thousand dollars in
debt right now
no they're upside down in these i
thought you said he oh no we're upside
down yeah
i'm sorry i owe's 10 more than on
twitter
yeah i shouldn't be so glib about that
but but they're upside down in these
cars yeah okay
but this is a this is a marriage we
we've got some big time marriage issues
man
she's you you're acting you're calling
out like well my wife doesn't want to
agree with me but
we got a 2021 that either you all of a
sudden saw the light or she talked you
into this
so you're buying you know i mean i
understand what you're rolling these
cars over but
man this is you this has to stop and you
guys
this is a marriage issue oh i think you
guys need counsel
i think you need counseling because it
is the counseling
step yeah yeah that that to me is is
step one
because i don't does it seem like you
guys are fighting and throwing pans and
pots at each other is that true
no no but i mean we've yesterday
listening to dave's talk
with colton from iowa city about the
same subject
um yeah i mean we we're we're fighting
you know over
um the same way as as anybody who's
first starting out with the
month to month budgeting the first few
months are going to be painful
like he said uh like dave said yesterday
so that's that's what we're going
through
so so let me let me talk to the money
side of things because i i agree with
ken
and and here's the thing with the money
not married i'm a single man
and so i i do not want to give marriage
advice but one of the things on a
money side that i can give advice to a
married couple or a single person
is that there has to be a clear vision
for the future
where where are we going babe what what
do we qualify
and call success for our marriage for
our family on the financial side of
things
is that so we can have financial freedom
so we can build our dream home
so we can take these dream vacations so
we can pass down wealth
and legacy to our kids and if that is
the case 253 thousand dollars in debt
which half of it are in cars
okay yep houses and cars so immediately
i think when you go to counseling the
argument is not about money
money comes next we need to get a clear
vision of what do we want
where are we going when we get that
clear vision
all the other stuff is going to be an
easy conversation because now it becomes
all right does this take us to our
vision
or does it take us away from our vision
so that's one thing i would do second
thing from a practical tip
get rid of these daggone cards yes you
need to sell them
and this means that if you have to go
take out a loan for twenty thousand
dollars
to cover the differences you just went
from about a hundred and ten thousand
down to twenty thousand dollars right
there yeah that's huge
but your wife's gotta be on board with
this is the point or else
you see what i'm saying i don't know if
you're in a position where you just if
she's gonna agree with you to do this
yeah i mean ao's right you you can make
some major headway by selling these cars
and by the way now's the time to do it
because the market for used cars
is at an all-time high but i would do it
soon but
could you go talk to her tonight i mean
let's let's be straight up with each
other
could you go in after this phone call
and go hey i'm selling both these cars
or she gonna fight you on this
uh no i i can't i can't even sell my
truck because i'm stuck with it i have
i have a camper so i need the truck to
pull it you got a camper for what the
family
yes you living in it yeah no
no no dude get rid
well you made a mistake telling us that
you dude the camper is cheaper to live
out of right now in in the
maryland area man listen man but you
just told me you weren't going to break
man
you making excuses i don't think it's
just your wife it's him too oh
absolutely right
well yeah you can't tell us on one hand
you're not living in the camper and then
say it's cheaper to live in
come on man listen this is this ain't
easy you keep listening to the show and
at one point you're gonna decide it's
time
yeah ao's done i'm done i hit mute
he's done he hung up on him he hung up
he's he's had him i'm sorry
no apologies